voting in iran's presidential election
is underway turnout's expected to be low
because of widespread
apathy after hundreds of candidates
including prominent moderates were
barred from standing
voters are also angry about the impact
of international sanctions unemployment
and hardline rule
a new day but not a new dawn
as the curtains rose at iran's elections
the old guard remains firmly in control
supreme leader ayatollah ali khamenei
casting his vote
after barring hundreds of reformist
candidates from running
with their choices limited many have
decided to stay away from the polls
turnout is projected at a record low
where are your minds i won't vote
because whether i do or not
someone has already been elected they
are only organizing the elections for
the media
posing for the cameras the man likely to
become iran's next president
hardline candidate ibrahim raisi is
poised to succeed the moderate hassan
ruani
shifting power even further towards the
conservative clerics
this will leave the hardliners in charge
of negotiations
to revive an international deal to limit
iran's
nuclear enrichment those who did turn
out to vote
lament the crippling u.s sanctions
imposed after the trump administration
withdrew from the deal
we don't have an issue with the way the
election is run or with the regime
but the state of the economy has been
hard on us
this problem should have been solved
if iran's new government fails to
address its economic woes
the queues could be even shorter next
time polls open
let's take a closer look at this with
journalist and political analyst [ __ ]
mortazavi who hosts the iran podcast
and joins us from washington dc uh
welcome to dw
let's let's start with the the
presidential candidates iran's guardian
council
whittled down hundreds of candidates to
just seven and then four dropped out
so what does this tell us about the
direction that the country's supreme
leader wants a country to take
well the hardliners who control the
guardian council the watchdog
that is responsible for qualifying or
disqualifying
seem to be attempting to consolidate
power and cut
any true competition or rivalry in this
election
for ibrahim raisi the hardline favor
because elections in iran have never
been free or fair but they have been
competitive
there has been some serious competition
in some of the previous elections and
ibrahimovic in fact
ran once before in 2017 and he lost
to hassan rouhani so this seems to be a
clearing
off the path for him to an easy victory
and preventing another embarrassing
defeat
for the current head of judiciary which
is raising okay so this is something
that often gets overlooked when when
we're looking at iranian
uh iran's movements in the world the
idea that there are power struggles
within the regime
definitely there are power struggles we
have to remember the supreme leader the
top person in power
is a hardliner he's the hardline person
in power and there's usually this
perception that it's a one-man show it's
one hardliner show but there
are definitely struggles within the
political system the moderates and their
formis
have had have created some serious
challenges to the hardliners and
the conservatives but this seems to be
this election
seems to be one more attempt to sort of
consolidate power and marginalize
uh as many reformists and moderates who
can create this serious challenge to the
hardline
grip and we have seen some of the
criticism and protests to this
mass disqualification even coming from
centrist politicians someone like ali
laurijani
who's not really a reformist himself
he's been a centrist hardliner but even
he was disqualified
from the race in fear that he could
create real competition for ibrahim
raising
tell us about ibrahim razi this man who
is likely to be the the winner
what can we expect from an iran led by
him
sure let me just make a note here that
it's still early to call even though the
moderate hemati is the underdog but iran
elections have also been full of
surprises so i'd like to wait until
the end of the voting which was just
extended for a few hours to see but
seems like abraham ricey has a very high
chance of winning this election without
real strong competition he's the current
head of judiciary an
ultra conservative hardline
member of iran's judicial system for the
past four decades with a very
controversial past
he has a record of gross violations of
human rights whose member of a death
committee in the 1980s responsible for
ordering
mass execution of iranian dissidents so
his
presidency his potential presidency is
going to make things very complicated
for iran especially iran's engagement
with the world
and specifically with the west with the
with the united states and its european
allies when it comes to issues
um beyond the nuclear deal which is
something that they are
um discussing right now in vienna that's
very clear thank you so much for
outlining that for us uh
thank you